thank you
[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
very very special episode of the careful
boys JK mukbang yeah Panda Rose guys do
this with your hand and then put the
food in front so that you can see we're
doing another
that's cute Ryan feed me feed me from
there if you got food join us we're all
eat ing together here on this special
episode I got a shrimp cocktail right
and today we are going to be talking
about
if it was your last meal to eat because
you're on death row what would your last
meal be that's tough bro and if it's
gonna start so the rest of us can just
eat damn that is a good one Anthony dude
Ryan thank you what is this [__]
hosts yeah post Alliance we work
together
so it's on me huh yeah you go first
what is your last meal last meal dude
and you're you're gonna be you'll be
dead and they'll give you anything
I'll do this dude I think it'd be like
Pine and chicken rice oh that's good
that's good and then from a particular
place
no uh
because they can get you some bad one
you got to tell them no that's true huh
where do you want it from I don't know I
wouldn't say cluck to go because I eat
that too much I think might be your last
meal
um it has to be some I would need a
Singaporean person to make a company oh
yeah also there's no limitation as to
like where it's coming from oh got it
okay oh yeah I would love for
um a Malaysian person of some sort or
same 40 person so if any guy what's the
difference between Malaysia or
Singaporean Hainan chicken
um
yeah don't do it I don't know actually
how come no one ever gets it from Hainan
you guys are asking me questions I can't
answer
isn't that what you always do to The
Host
I think what the [__] is this is the
intervention for me dude I think it's
kind of like KFC what do you mean you
don't really go to Kentucky that's true
that's very true it just it's just where
it came from Kentucky Fried Chicken in
Kentucky tastes better
you didn't even just call it Fried
Chicken there
good shot 11 herbs and spices I think I
would do that and then like a bowl of um
spicy wontons have you had those like
the oh yeah like the Sichuan style
Sichuan style
yeah kind of very similar to that kind
of style right oh and then maybe like um
it was just really good and I was
talking about it this morning there's
really good seafood Korean Chinese like
noodle soup have you guys ever had that
it's like red a bunch of fish shrimp and
like it's so good is that jumbo yeah
yeah yeah
I would have something like that dude I
think that would be my [__] that's a
lot of food dude there's a lot of food
your boy could put that down I think are
you doing a dim sum style Yeah well yeah
also because you're on death row you
have to imagine that you haven't eaten
anything but prison food for the past
forever bro dim sum might be a solid one
too bro like a whole [__] spread yeah
like it's undefeated
we're like oh man I can go on and on oh
yeah I would have my mom surprise me
with three meals that she used to cook
me when I was a kid
should we do this
um meatloaf steak
[Laughter]
fruit salad
in a jello form I have a tuna sandwich
oh man throw a tuna melt bro a tuna melt
dog a tuna mayonnaise oh my god with a
grilled cheese you don't like tuna melts
I don't like mayonnaise you don't like
bro you sure you're white dude no
mayonnaise is solid though what about
the aioli like aioli yeah that's
mayonnaise dude no no no
they just put flavors in it so it's like
it's Mayo with garlic or garlic herb I
think I always made with the yolk and
mayonnaise isn't oh it's egg whites come
on come to mice
I think you're right but you know at the
same time it's like ah the [__] do you
like aioli that's mayonnaise
surprise that's mayonnaise
what's the third one yes I like it
mayonnaise yeah chicken salad mayonnaise
yeah check us out with raisins now for
real what's your third what's your third
um the third one would be
what else would you make you just what
kind of cut of steak you said steak
filet mignon yeah how do you like your
filet medium rare always nice wrong
answer okay
answer is medium
medium well that's a medium rare
lemon chicken pasta now this one guy who
ordered his Burger well done and I was
like this is the last date really bro a
burger well done is kind of that's why
I'm trying to turn you off it's kind of
fire only a Smash Burger can be well
done that's true is it a thick is it a
steakhouse right yeah it was like that
when they ask you
that means that burger is not meant to
be well done no even the waitress was
like are you sure about that are you
sure about that even I was like are you
sure about that I was like you like your
steak I mean your your burger well done
you kept saying like that did he feel
judged
yeah what did he say Khalia was trying
to say [__]
cool uh-huh you still haven't said
number three
she said steak steak
um I don't know it'd be some sort of
pasta I love pasta oh bro you know
what's like a seafood pasta like a your
mom makes a good seafood pasta like a
clam linguine oh I was just thinking
that
oh you know what's also really good that
I would want to add to my what just a
nice plate of like sauce no you're
already dead
oh that's good bro you're trying to be
like [__] bucking all Buffet right
now you can't I wouldn't do it all
afternoon yeah all right but as long as
my mom made it yeah and it came from her
you like chili your mom makes a mean
chili yeah she does actually what about
sloppy joes yeah we have a few of those
yeah but what if we're on death row and
you're like 80.
[Laughter]
the fact that you're on death row and
put you in bad terms with her oh [__]
she's like I'm not gonna make her in the
meals yeah
damn you know what my mom used to do to
my brother and I if we didn't finish our
dinner what'd she do she'd be like guess
you're having it for breakfast you're
gonna have her for lunch and then dinner
the next day I remember being so nasty
that happened to me to the point where
like I wasn't eating for like two days
that's cruel and unusual it is you end
up with tilapia for breakfast it's
disgusting a lot of people from
breakfast is good protein first I think
it's also good to start the day and
unusual when your sibling ate it all
and they see you eat tilapia for
breakfast oh yeah
and you're all washable if they finish
it all they could get new breakfast
no that's a good rule I like that Great
rule then they get waffles I'm like eat
your leftovers bro don't be wasting food
did they teach you how to save
or were you like [__] up
I waste food all the time now really no
I eat everything
what about you that's you doing the
right thing now
um chicken salad
I mean I love KFC it's like my favorite
[__] really yeah I love KFCs
that's awesome have you ever had
Louisiana famous
huh have you ever had Louisiana Famous
Fried Chicken
the fried chicken but I think it's just
like a nostalgic thing
love original recipe so much so good not
even extra Christmas no no hell no
really so did you did you know about the
all-you-can-eat KFC that used to be in
Hawaiian Gardens what no no yup no one
ever believes me that it was real
um it's a little city that no one goes
to but there's a casino it's like close
to Carson right and Cerritos
yeah there was an all-you-can-eat KFC
right next to the casino damn seven
bucks back it was like really back in
the day yeah but it was really
depressing coleslaw too everything I
love the coleslaw just they would just
constantly come out and dump all the
food into a like a salad bar kind of
arrangement you just go and you Philly
play it up I do not like mayonnaise Bros
crazy
she don't like coleslaw do you like
aioli
so you only make that with the yolk
so like research it was great so KFC KFC
all nothing but KFC
coleslaw nice yeah you should work with
them that'd be sick they'd be lucky to
have you you got potato wedges you go
mash
they don't [__] sell the potato
wedges anymore really yeah man so angry
do they smell like regular french fries
do you remember old school the
rotisserie gold yeah did you like it
when they were making that I still like
original recipes
their biscuits are banging in there you
know what I like when KFC and AMW orgy
together
and you can get a a w flow floaty coke
with KFC they do that with Taco Bell a
lot they just put a chicken breast in
the coke
original recipe
I can't believe you just have one place
it's just chaos I respect that I like
that you like KFC it's smart
that makes it easier for everybody it
does yeah the guards love guards will
love you they'll [__] hate me they're
like good I want a gift receive it and
your orders wrong you're like [__] this
is the last meal
what about you Anthony are we doing the
thing where like my mother won't cook
for me because of well we did do like it
what we did yeah that's
Colleen's crime
we'll figure something out for you
definitely my mom my mom's trying on
chicken yeah she makes a mean one
you know when you just grow up on
something yeah yeah yeah it's Nostalgia
your mom makes Heinen chicken yeah
do a lot of moms make that Mama made it
that's true is it like it's kind of easy
to make and you make it in a batchy like
a big batch you just put salt on the
chicken and boil it put some ginger you
just need to know how to make that sauce
thing right yeah the green and then the
ginger she makes a specific type of
sauce more the soy sauce based one with
like the sugar and the garlic or
whatever you've never tasted a sauce
similar to your mom's out in the wild
anywhere
oh it's just not as good interesting
that's cool you know when your mom makes
you the food too you also associate it
with abundance
because you don't like when you eat when
you buy a portion from like a restaurant
that's the portion you get when you eat
at home you might eat the whole [__]
chicken yourself yeah you know what I
mean
and I think there's memory there's a lot
of memories tied to food so then
sometimes you just want it a certain way
because it's nostalgic
my mom can't cook but there was a dish
that she made that was pretty good was
fried fish but other than that I like my
own cooking better yeah
so that's it you don't only do Hainan so
you cook for yourself I think if it was
one meal I'll just go with that add more
stuff like me please
what if they're like you also get a
drink with that yeah a drink
it could be anything I'll probably go
out with like an old-fashioned that's
nice
you're a classic dude
but then you can't have water
I'm gonna die anyway
sure I was gonna cook for himself and
then use the utensils to accept it then
you can't have one I'm gonna make my own
food I'm gonna ask them to give me a
barbecue oh that's cool what would he
make
um I would grill a ribeye but they won't
give you any tools because you might
Escape so you gotta do it with your
hands only
okay and you don't get any water
[Laughter]
mayonnaise is abundant you guys just get
no water yeah because of what you did to
that kid yeah
you can okay you said you can be quiet
back there yeah [__] you okay yeah yeah
Bumble away we already know
I want to buy a steak ribeye real ribeye
steak from where like Angus I do I cook
them for myself right
I think that's my favorite cut to to do
on a grill so good about the combination
of fire and the taste of ribeye so good
dude it's undefeated you can't beat that
yeah it's hard to be over rice bro yep
with corn and soy sauce I know it's
weird no it's good that sounds very good
and I'll do a Dungeness crab
Dungeness crab that's really good
with lemon and you don't have to worry
about market price too yeah buttered
lemon I'm good the Vietnamese style
holster when you get the lime and then
the salt and pepper dipping yeah oh
that's a bomb and you know can I add
something to my yeah go ahead they're
already getting nine courses
wow nice fire it up what's that fire
roasted barbecued corn it's that Mexican
corn your favorite you put some uh some
um mayonnaise on it with some queso
fresco and some like you know tahin or
something yeah bro oh
I can't wait to be on death yeah you're
you're dead and they're still bringing
your courses do you know do you know
what Rose City Pizza is yeah love that
place have you had the elote pizza
very very good pretty good once you once
you invite me when you go I've never
been really but but I've had the pizza
app like they'll deliver it to places
that I'm at like if I'm at a party or an
event Rose City sponsors it and you can
try all they're like yeah luckily I mean
I've never been to the actual brick and
mortar it's very nice
I've had it just not there all right
what's your death bro not pizza but oh
I'm gonna add a I'm gonna add a dessert
no you can't add any more dude you're
dead already you're already dead they're
just put the dessert in your dead body I
gotta
I get a um Cinnabon
am I gonna send a bun that's a good
choice that's a good choice with some
ice cream because I'm like you know what
I'm about to die yeah I can eat whatever
man Dairy all the way let's go oh yeah
are you lactose normally
no but I stay away from dairy because it
um it gives it white supremacist
overtone
[Laughter]
oh I get a nice Coke too that's what I
think I thought I was gonna die so I'll
just take a regular Coke that's my my
death row meal would definitely have
crying tiger in it what's crying tiger
that's the Thai steak with the spices
sometimes they call it tiger
crying tiger crying tiger steak is so
freaking good and then uh my mom used to
make this potato and egg omelette as a
side dish usually but that's I want to
go out I want that in my mouth when I'm
dead
to instead of having your final dinner
it has to be a final day and then you
get breakfast lunch and dinner damn
let's do that we're hooking up Jesus
these murderers for your money
yeah it's [__] ten dollars we use a
lot of wasteful money on tax dollars
yeah because I was like thinking I just
was doing there's my favorite like
breakfast what's your favorite breakfast
give me your breakfast I want Uber
pancakes
it's appropriating dude no okay
I want a prime rib that's okay
prime rib locomoco prime rib Locomo have
you had one garlic rice oh whoa dude
that sounds really good bro if you come
to Hawaii come on I like that nobody's
uh death row meal had anything to do
with what we currently are eating yeah
oh I mean I'll take a plate with it and
like a fork and napkins yeah I'll have
all that stuff what about a dessert
round what would you have other than the
mango sticky rice yeah well you already
answered yeah churros corn chocolate
would be good a what churros and
chocolate that's pretty man dipping
chocolate with churross the charge I
will say cinnamon bun Cinnabon is real
good that's a good answer I forgot about
it I love Cinnabon the center part oh
just like a bunch of Center Parts like
the whole dozen Cinema but you just take
the outside right correct that's really
good man I don't really like sweets that
much but I like ice cream that's it it's
so delicious I hate I like Cinnabon like
you're gonna say cinnamon I'm like I
don't care about Cinnabon at all part of
me the more I eat cinnamon the more I'm
like
Kentucky Fried Cinnabon original recipe
on it yeah
so you're like more of a Savory guy yeah
yeah
I I'll eat ice cream like I don't like
cake vanilla ice cream
sorbet salt and straw gelato
Savory ice cream yeah Savory ice cream
and I see what it would be yeah
you saw caramel yeah
it's hard to beat that you know what
else I can go out on
go to McDonald's right you get a hash
brown talk dirty to me bro you take this
strawberry jam in the butter
you butter that [__] up all the hash
browns on the hash brown I'm telling you
right now you take a McDonald's hash
brown with the strawberry jam and butter
they have strawberry jam you're fancy
what a freak [__] delicious that's
[__] amazing how did you how did you
come up with that like a fat ass sexy oh
yeah it used to be fast baby sex thing
oh wow this Jam's weird I'm gonna get in
the comments if you can relate or if
you've ever tried it all right dude you
know what I would like I would like to
get a large fries but made in the old
school lard way from like this yeah
Frieda beef tallow dude how they used to
do it they used to do it yeah and it's
funny because they do that at
restaurants now like oh this is a great
thing yeah whereas when they were doing
at McDonald's they're like what the [__]
yeah
right right right right right crayons
fat exactly and and get the uh the dark
meat chicken nuggets
they don't got that no more either and
they were always shaved as the boot yeah
a little boot exactly yes those are the
dark meat ones I would love to to taste
that again because it's like still fresh
in my mind but I'm gonna lose it man
yeah everyone used to be trans fat
phobic
and then they switched to vegetable oil
it can what about you you're about to
die
yeah what weird ass food do you want to
eat red bean I'm thinking about it yeah
that's actually I actually would eat
Popeyes wow
that's tight I like Popeyes yeah do you
like Popeyes that much I've never seen
you I I eat it after the gym it's
[__] do you eat that after the gym
only who could eat that after a gym and
still look like that drink a protein
shake try your ghost pepper wings yeah
it's good I like it
okay
I eat it and I try to limit myself from
eating it because I know it's bad for
you but if I'm about to die I would eat
that
dude Popeyes how much can't be that bad
for you if you're I eat food all the
time and I don't want to just like all
right
my last meal is gonna be something I
always eat I want something that like
you know it's like more like a treat I
guess we're getting Popeyes tomorrow for
lunch eh hey oh [__] do you want to get
Popeyes tomorrow I'm down I'm so down
for Popeyes and some honey butter
biscuits yeah come on we'll just send
pictures to Bart
foreign